- What do we do about this,
other than protesting and
chaining ourselves to trees?
Yes, by all means let's do that,
but we also need to figure
out ways where we can emulate
some of these more careful
management practices
based on being on the land and listening
and trying to protect
those wonderful resources.
And all that at the same time
is protecting biodiversity,
carbon storage,
and all while climate is changing
and making it harder and
harder and harder to do that.
So how can we help these forests?
So, I started a project
about five years ago
to try to address some of these things
called The Mother Tree Project.
The basic idea is taking
that basic research
on tree communication and connection
and applying it in forestry practices
so that we can actually
look after the basic things
that we need in order to
have a life on this planet
which means protecting our forests,
protecting the carbon stocks
that are in those forests,
the biodiversity that's in them.
And so, we wanted to retain
mother trees in different amounts
and configurations with
the idea that we knew
that they were essential to regeneration
and essential to protecting
all the other creatures in the forest.
And we also wanted to
look at genetic gradients
because we knew already that the rate
of climate change is so fast,
the velocity is so high
that trees cannot migrate
as quickly as we need them to in order
to retain forests on our earth,
to retain forested landscape.
We're gonna have to help them migrate.
We're gonna have to help
species and genotypes move
because we've made it too fast for them
to do it on their own.
I'm gonna show you some of
our early results on this.
We focused on one particular
forest type, Douglas fir,
because it's got this big, broad range
across British Columbia.
So these are undergraduate
and graduate students
and they are the
lifeblood of this project.
It's a hundred-year project.
I'm gonna be gone well before the forest
reaches a teenage year,
and so they're gonna be the ones
that are carrying this into the future.
This is the biggest
experiment I've ever designed.
It's probably one of the
biggest climate experiments
in forests in North America.
So we have actually a total of 27 forests
that have been treated in different ways
where we retain mother trees
in different configurations
and compare them to an
uncut primary forest,
so a native forest.
And then we've taken that native forest
and cut out different patches of trees,
leaving these different mother trees
in different amounts and configurations.
So the 60% means that
we cut out gaps of trees
and left 60% of the mother trees
and thinned them from below
to try to boost their vigor.
And then the next one,
this 30% is we created
larger gaps in the forest
and left patches of 30%,
so just smaller patches.
This 10% is what's known
as a seed tree method.
It's a very common
forest harvesting method
across Europe and North America
where you leave individual trees.
The problem with it is
that what we have found
across British Columbia anyway
is that about 1/3 of those trees
are dead within five years.
And that's part of the
reasoning behind having
these 30 and 60% patches as well,
to protect the mother trees
from dying, from blowing over,
or just dying from stress
or shock from losing its
neighbors and its family.